foreign
Mitch is in Atlanta Mitch welcome to the
show
hey how you doing thank you oh man this
is incredible thanks for taking my call
oh happy to do it thanks for calling wow
here's where I am I in 2008 I'm a
full-time realtor I've been real for 25
years and 2008-9 and the market changed
I lost everything so I did foreclosure
uh a year and a half later I bought a
house of forty thousand dollars
and my parents are Renovators so they
came down and renovated the house so the
houses I had no debt you know I paid the
house off it's probably worth about 300
000 now and I had no no debt you know I
do a debit card I got 6 000 in checking
I've got 23 000 in savings
I I have a lot of free time I'm still
work full-time as a realtor but I have a
lot of free time and
I don't know what to do now I don't know
if I know if I could score anymore you
know no debts uh zero uh and I don't I
don't spend on anything I don't pay I
don't buy anything
I just don't know what to do at this
point if my my parents when if they pass
away which would be the worst day of my
life they have about 13 houses so me and
my fam my brother my sister would be
we'll do be looking pretty good
with money when you say you don't know
what to do do you mean do with your day
because you're just not interested in
selling houses anymore is that what
you're saying no I do I do I just I want
to have a retirement and I just don't
know where to how to do it I mean
you know I've got the six percent I've
got money in the bank but I need
retirement and I don't know it sounds
like the real estate properties would
become part of your portfolio to cash
flow some retirement correct
yes but for now let's say your parents
live much longer what would you do if
you retired tomorrow where would your
income come from
um well I I do I do cars as a hobby have
you been investing at all into the
market
no I no that's the problem I don't know
where to invest and what to do I I had
zero clue about what to do from here so
you have no 401K no retirement Accounts
at all no IRAs no okay that would be a
good first step how old are you
I'm 59 I guess I'm at step seven of your
baby steps how much cash you have in the
bank
I got 22 000 in savings and six thousand
checking
that would be basically your emergency
fund and spending money maybe a little
bit more so we still need to figure out
retirement income what are you making
per year on average
50 between 50 and 60 000. so you're not
selling a ton of homes
no I'm not doing a lot
um Market's crazy it's up and down but
no I'm not doing it a ton of ton of
business well I tell you what this is
complex so George let's hold uh Mitch
over because there's a lot of people
that are in his shoes Mitch George's
going to walk you through step by step
what you need to do so you said your
parents have a bunch of property they
have about 13 properties that you would
inherit solely
uh be me my brother my sister so we're
probably looking about maybe 600
000 each properly worth of properties do
you think they would want to sell it or
do they want to keep it and use the cash
flow as income uh we've been they've
been talking about selling and they've
sold one they bought another one they
just buy and sell and I don't know you
know they're 80 and 83 years old and
they just don't want to stop working uh
they're both really in really good shape
um lately close to Nashville too so I'm
I'm that's close to my hometown cool
um but I you know I just don't so let's
find a plan for Mitch aside from
whatever happens later down the line I
want to make sure that you know what to
do in the next 5 10 15 years
yes so on one side financially we've got
to get you investing you're in a great
place to do it because you have no debt
including a mortgage payment and so
there's a lot of options for real estate
agents number one you can look into IRAs
Roth IRA is going to be a great option
for you and you can look into are you
self-employed no employees
self-employed okay you can also look
into a SEP IRA which is for
self-employed folks that have no
employees and you can contribute up to
25 of your income which is incredible
comparatively to a lot of other
investing options
okay so those are two options right off
the bat that I can think of solo 401ks
are also an option I would connect with
a smartvester pro at ramseysolutions.com
who can walk you through all of the
options for your specific situation
do I look pretty good on paper with my
age and no debt I mean yes
you need more income as far as retiring
tomorrow you'd have nothing to live off
of and so that's the only concern you're
in a great spot financially compared to
the rest of America and so the goal
right now is to get you a little Nest
Egg to create some cash flow so that
when you want to retire 10 years from
now and not have to work you're able to
do that
so a second job is what I need to do I
think well I'm gonna push you on that
I don't know if you need a second job I
think you need either to do better in
your job or get a better job and I'm not
in any way uh criticizing you but I
lived in the Atlanta area for 11 years
and a real estate agent who's only
making fifty thousand dollars a year in
the Atlanta area
either
doesn't want to make much more than that
or doesn't really like it and there's
something that's kind of holding you
back from really getting after it how
many homes do you sell in 2020 hold on
hold on a second I want to get that
answer there what so I just nailed it
what did I need yeah because I'm I've
done it for 25 years and and
you know I people are just not the same
as they used to be and you know dealing
with the public people were just mean
they're just mean people out there and
I'm just having to deal hard time
dealing with people's attitudes and
everything else
okay so that's what's keeping you from
getting after it you just you have a
there's not much to encourage you to get
out there and kill something and drag it
home
correct okay correct all right so that's
because you're not really wired for this
I don't know that people are any more
rude or or than they were 20 years ago
it's a tough business to get out there
and put yourself out there because it's
got a lot of rejection associated with
it if you don't get people listening
with you uh or people uh you know buying
from you and and I just I think you're
in the wrong business
car's my passion uh real estate used to
be my fashion what do you need when you
say cars are your passion what do you
mean flipping them renovating them
mechanics what are we talking about I
have a car I have a car Channel on
YouTube and and I just love finding cars
and saving them from being crushed or
whatever what do you do with them when
you save them
well I've helped people I found how
people will call me and I have tried to
you know find cars for people and I've
done that a lot lately but I don't make
any really money off that but I just
like buying these okay especially
Jaguars and Trans Am I just love these
cars and I want to save as much as I can
and me saving a car all right so while I
love that I love that we're beginning to
see something that fires you up okay so
you love restoration renovation that
there's something there so you need to
get into that type of business you've
got to be making money
and real estate I mean again you can get
over this and kind of bite the bullet
and start getting more active and I
would recommend that for the next
however many months it's going to take
for you to get clear on what it is you
really want to do and what you may have
to do to get qualified to do it but if
you just started like flipping cars and
getting serious about it you may have to
sell a house or two and take some of
that commission and put it towards now
I'm gonna go buy a car I'm going to buy
a car for five or six grand that was
about three to six grand of work I can
sell it for 20. all right the profit you
just said exactly what I'm wanting to do
then do it do it because here's the deal
you should be highly motivated right now
because you're not making enough money
Mitch you should be making six figures
or more
but but to get you to six figures is all
about getting serious and and I think
you've got a highly highly motivated
cause right now which is I need to get
busy
funding my retirement I've done some
good things I've lived on less than I
make I have no debt that's all great but
now it's about income you need to do
something that makes your heart swell
brother
not free
you're right
what's going on you're right I know
where's this emotion coming from what's
going on this I'm just tired I'm just
tired of uh
just tired of getting out there and
doing the best I can but I keep getting
you know it's just don't seem to be
working out it's not working anymore
it's not working out because it's
actually not your best and it's not
because you're lazy
it's because you got yourself into a
role that's just not a good fit for you
it's why I teach we are on purpose Mitch
well you're doing what we were born to
do when we use what we do best that's
talent to do something we love that's
passion to produce results that matter
to us and you've never had that
what were you doing when you were on
fire
I was well I was really loving when I
did that the thing I love to do is find
homes for people that needed a home
I I love being a part of their new
adventure and their new life
well something changed so we don't need
to recycle what we've talked about so
far but you can re-gather that maybe you
should start looking for the people that
really need the extra help people that
are looking for a house that they don't
know where to find it maybe it's lower
income or maybe it's but you need to get
some juice man and and you think about
the cars and all of that but start doing
something that you love that you look
forward to when you get out of bed not
something you're worried about dealing
with and that's what's going on that's
why you're exhausted to the point of
emotional
you're you're nailing it right on the
head everything you're saying is exactly
what I thought actually I knew it I just
need to hear it you needed to push you
need it yeah you needed a push there is
work that you were put on this planet to
do and there are people on the other
side of that work Mitch
you need to reconnect with your heart
and work that fires you up because you
look forward to it you enjoy it
and it produces a result
that gives you satisfaction and
significance George I love this there's
the the he's literally emotionally
drained well because it's been so long
he thinks it's too late that but it's
been so long
since he got up and finished a day of
work where he felt good about himself
that's a heavy weight absolutely hey
Mitch I want to send you Ken's book from
paycheck to purpose as well as his get
clear career assessment I think those
two resources are going to help you step
into this next chapter of your life call
it an encore career but you're not done
Mitch you've known a lot of contribution
to make in this world and I'm excited to
see you step into that with no debt what
a great place to start thank you for the
call brother this is the Ramsey Show